Greiner she's returning to the only WNBA
team she has ever played for Source
confirms the CBS news that the Phoenix
Mercury will resign the eight-time
All-Star to a one-year contract the deal
comes less than three months after
Griner was freed from a Russian prison
the 32 year old free agent led the
Mercury to the WNBA finals in 2021
Greiner was then detained in Russia for
10 months after Customs officials
arrested her at a Moscow airport finding
Vape cartridges containing cannabis oil
in her luggage when Greiner was released
in December she wrote on Instagram that
she intended to play basketball again
for the Mercury